♪ (TENSE SULTRY MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
People!
Let's make the dream happen.
We need a fucking hit.
Action!
SPEAKER:
These people are wondering
whether you still got that fire.
I'm worried she's having
another psychotic break.
-It's a lot.
-BOTH: It's a lot.
SPEAKER:
So give 'em what they love.
Look at the camera
and fuck everyone in America?
Fuck 'em and fuck 'em good.
Los Angeles is where
all the monsters of the world
come to gather.
Trust no one.
(WHISPERS) Just me.
SPEAKER 2:
I feel like everyone's
losing their minds.
-Where did he come from?
-(YELPS)
Let people enjoy sex, drugs,
and hot girls, okay?
Stop trying
to cockblock America.
Fire up the mic, let's go.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
I need full control.
No matter fucking what.
♪ I... ♪
♪ Love to love you, baby ♪
So where should we start?
(CLAPPING) Woo! Woo!